hello Suzy's world I know this isn't the
type of content you would usually expect
on me but I'm feeling kind of
experimental right now so let me know if
this is something you'd like to see for
me in this poll right here and don't
worry this doesn't count towards my
video for this week just something that
I thought I'd try out so here we see the
Death Note falling into the human world
as it should
the one difference being that it falls
into an area where white is sitting by
himself as opposed to in the anime where
he just notices that fall past the
window and happens to be the first one
to pick it up so what's the difference
in this film you could say that the
Shinigami who dropped it was giving it
to light on purpose knowing full well
what he's capable of doing with it
you'll notice that the Death Note itself
has some strange markings on the top
corners this could be something as
simple as the book having been removed
from the chain that it uses to sling it
around his shoulder that would mean that
in this movie light actually has of the
youths death note whereas in the anime
he has the Death Note that is a you
stole from Sydow so you may not have
multiple notebooks in this version and
here he is here's the Luke looks great
in this light no pun intended gods of
death love apples and here we see an
apple moving on its own but also other
objects swirling around the room I can't
say for sure if the presence of a
Shinigami is what is causing that
swirling but I will say it is it could
be even more of a security threat to
light in the anime he had to worry about
whether you simply picking up and eating
an apple on cam as it would appear like
a floating Apple that disappears to the
naked eye but this swirling phenomena
could prove to be much more of a
distraction okay so the film takes place
in Seattle because this is an American
version of Death Note
but why Seattle as opposed to any other
American city my theory is that it's
most reminiscent of Tokyo both cities
feature a tall skinny observation tower
in Seattle it's the Space Needle in
Tokyo it's Tokyo Tower
both have a ferris wheel on their
skyline as well as you'll see later the
ferris wheel comes into play into the
plot somehow I couldn't find any real
high schools abbreviated with the
letters NX H in Seattle but let me know
if you can find any
, what's interesting here is that the
girl on the right looked more like Misa
Amane
mostly because of her hair but this girl
in the middle looks to be an actress
named Margaret Whaley according to IMDB
she's playing a character named Mia
Sutton Missa mia s it seems like Mia may
be the American counterpart it would
also seem that she's a bit younger if
she's still in high school and she
probably isn't a celebrity anymore maybe
just a popular cheerleader instead also
she smokes now and what about Matt and
they've just turned him into a female
for this movie just kidding it's hard to
tell from this lighting but this looks
to be a guy named Lee Keith Stanfield
the actor who's playing L if so this is
a big departure from the usual white
shirt blue jeans L that were used to
seeing he's also wearing a mask that
covers half of his face which could be
paired with a visor or glasses of some
sort to protect his identity as you
probably know kita needs a name and his
face to kill someone using the Death
Note
unlike desc we see another apple and
some kind of little propeller based
machine maybe a drone of some kind this
tells us not only that light is still a
genius in this adaptation but also could
foreshadow the use of a helicopter later
if you've seen the show you know that
one of the most pivotal turning points
in the series takes place while light is
in a helicopter in the shot we learned
that light is left-handed as opposed to
him being right-handed in a series and
the Japanese live-action adaptation this
makes me wonder if this will be used
against him in the movie if you aren't
aware left-handed writers tend to run
their hand against the page when writing
in English or any other language that
goes from left to right and as a result
their hand smudges against the text that
they've just written l could use this to
determine that kita is left-handed if
you were to obtain the notebook this all
do narrows down the search a lot
considering that most people are
right-handed this area has the same red
lighting as the area where we saw Elle
walking before meaning that L may
actually be investigating the scene of
the crime himself this once again goes
against what were accustomed to with
Elle's character in the light novel the
Los Angeles Vivi murder cases we learned
that Elle likes to work behind the
scenes and sends Naomi meta to do the
physical investigation for him we also
see the name kita being used which is
noteworthy considering the characters
have been given Americanized names like
light Turner instead of Light Yagami and
Mia Sutton instead of meets Amane but in
the anime the Mei
ketta originates from the japanese
pronunciation of the English word killer
so perhaps Japan does play some part in
this movie after all in the anime Keita
does occasionally leave little calling
cards or false clues to Elle when he
kills criminals but for the most part he
just leaves the media to come up with
the idea of Keita on their own this
message on the wall seems much more
blatant here's this girl again and if
this is her making out with white then
there's a good chance that she is in
fact supposed to be Misa
unless of course director Adam Wingard
is just throwing us a curve ball and
that's actually Kiyomi Takada which
would make some sense because the fact
that light meets her in college in the
anime so he could just be meeting her in
highschool in this film towards the end
of the trailer we see this Ferris wheel
getting crushed and light seems to be
saving someone this leads me to ponder a
few possibilities is this part of one of
life's plans much like how he causes the
catastrophe on the bus to learn more
about Rey penber is this the work of a
Shinigami trying to get there Death Note
back I only suggest this because of the
way that the ferris wheel bends in as if
an invisible force is crushing it and
one more possibility is that someone
else has a Death Note and they're trying
to kill someone on the ferris wheel or
send a message to light let me know what
you think down in the comments below and
don't forget to weigh in and if you like
this type of video if you're new to
Suzy's world and you love Death Note
then please consider subscribing to the
channel I'm a filmmaker and I love to
make psychological horror content so it
should be right up your alley I've got
new Horrors every other week so ring
that death Bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive
[Music]